- Oh my gosh! I love this.
- Thank you.
- You look so cute, oh my gosh!
You look so great, the
last time we talked though
actually wasn't on my
show, it was on yours.
- It was on my podcast
that you came on to.
- It was so fun.
- We had such a great time with you.
- I felt like I could have
talked to y'all for hours.
- We hear that a lot from people,
people love talking to us.
- No I'm telling you, it's
such a comfortable, it's fun
and it's informative and
you're talking about stuff
that maybe we didn't
talk about, I love that.
- Well and I feel like for
people who may not know,
I have a podcast, it's called
"Mayim Bialik's Breakdown"
and I host it with my
partner, Jonathan Cohen
and it is all about mental health
but also the stories behind the things
we've been told by doctors and therapists
and it's really fun.
And when you came on, I
was so excited.(laughs)
- I literally was so
excited and I also was like,
"Man, I hope they know I
don't wear make up at home."
(audience laughs)
- Well and we ended up
talking a lot about body image
and how we present ourselves
and I have a tremendous
amount of anxiety about that
and a lot of respect for the
way that you present yourself,
when we actually talked a lot about it,
to this day Jonathan says to me,
"What would Kelly Clarkson tell you?"
(audience laughs)
- No, it is true though.
I love that about the podcast,
I just thought, what a cool thing,
I think a lot of people start podcasts
but I love what's special
about yours I think is
all the walls are down, you're
talking about everything,
it's a very comfortable
and fun environment
and also for people that maybe
don't know that side of me
or that part of me that I
don't talk about anywhere else,
I thought it was really cool.
- Well and that's what a
lot of our guests say, like,
"Gosh! I've never shared this before,"
"I've never talked about this before"
and we we had Matthew McConaughey on
and the first thing I said to him is,
"Do you have any idea who I am?"
and he was like, "No." (laughs)
- Oh my god, I love you, what?
- And I was like, "Well, my
pebbles isn't from Texas"
and I think that's how
you got, I was like,
I don't know who had to have
sex with who to get you here
but that's amazing.
- Wait, how in the world do
you not know who you are?
- Because he's Matthew McConaughey,
he can do whatever he want.
- You've literally been on huge shows.
- He's very busy being himself,
but I just thought it was amazing
that he was acting like, "Hi!"
and I'm like, "You have no idea who I am"
and this is so much fun.
- He's like one of those talkers
that loves a good conversation.
- Now he knows who I am.
- Yeah, now he knows.